You've endorsed Joe Biden. Um,
you and I have connected on a number of political topics that we're both
passionate about. And I remember you saw,
I saw a tweet from you championing local journalism,
which I could not agree more with, uh,
universal healthcare and universal basic income you think should be on the
table. Now, given the nature of the crisis, we're in the midst of, uh,
did you have like a, an arc politically, you,
was it something that you and your family were interested in from a while ago?
Or, or did you just, uh, start paying more attention more recently?
Uh, no, I've always been engaged. Uh,
one of the things I admire about the NBA players is they're a lot more active
than I was at that age. I was pretty self-centered at that point,
worried about my own career. So I think I've been more active,
but I was always engaged. I grew up in a, in a, you know,
my parents are conservative. Um, for me, the arc was,
as I was, I was always socially pretty liberal. You know,
I just didn't understand why anybody cared.
If you were sleeping with somebody of the same sex or what the color of your
skin was or any of those things. Um,
but I think I've certainly had an arc in terms
of economic issues. Um, you know,
I think at one point I was a, um, you know,
balanced the budget guy, um,
and still am to a degree. My,
the difference between me and and conservatives would probably be,
I I'd raise taxes and bring in more money so we could help more people. Um,
but recently,
right before you started running for president,
so these two things really propelled me,
my wife and I had watched it's probably a three or four year old
documentary that Robert Rice did. Um, when he was teaching at Cal,
he still is. And, you know,
he was talking about trickle down, doesn't work,
you know, going up, building the middle class.
So people have more money to spend.
That's what builds an economy and helps everyone.
And so we watched that made all kinds of sense.
Trickled down has never made any sense to me whatsoever.
Like this idea that they're going to create jobs up here.
Like I know I've never even run a business, but if I run a restaurant,
the only reason I'm going to hire more waiters or waitresses is I have more
customers.
Like you can give me a tax break and put another a hundred thousand in my
pocket. I'm not going out to hire anybody.
I'm not going to all of us.
Somebody, if I have the need to hire him. So Robert Reisch made sense to me.
If now I have more customers in my restaurant, I do better.
I hire more people, they do better. And so I watched that,
that a lot of sense. I learned a lot from that. And then, I mean,
within months,
if not even weeks after watching that you're on stage talking
about universal basic income,
which that idea goes exactly with that,
putting more money in people's pockets.
And so I will say that's a more recent thing to me. Um,
within the last year of saying, wow, this makes a lot of sense.
It's, it's not only more humane Farrow to people in our
society, but to me that helps everybody,
including the people at the top.
Yep. Yeah. If you're running a business, you know what you need,
you need customers with money to show up. Uh, you know,
and if you're in an environment right now where everyone was being sent home,
uh, like it's like, who are you going to profit from? You know, you,
you look outside, we can't all be Amazon, you know,
I guess Amazon is still doing all right. Uh, so, uh,
so this is the trickle up economy. And I, I saw the same documentary you saw by,
um, with, uh, Robert Reich. And, um,
he's been a very powerful and consistent voice in this direction.
Keeps on writing books keeps on pounding the table, making the case. Um, uh,
and the economy has just gotten more and more extreme over time. Uh,
it was the most extreme winner take all economy in the history of the world,
pre pandemic. And then the pandemic just, uh,
turned everything up to 11. Like it just sped everything up.
Well, and here in central Florida,
we have felt that about as much as anybody because, you know,
we don't have a lot of business here. I mean,
it's a tourism business and we're in the service, you know,
it's a service economy.
So we got a lot of people working low wage jobs here.
We have the biggest affordable housing crisis in the United States.
Um, because we're playing, we're paying people 10, 12,
$15 an hour and that's it. And there's,
there's no upward mobility when you're running a ride at Disney
world, you know? And so we can make our unemployment numbers look okay,
but those are not high paying jobs.
And then when people quit traveling and quit going to those
things in a pandemic, I mean, it is really, really been bad.
Um, I know the local, the biggest local food shelter, uh,
in the area has, you know,
been doing about triple the number of meals that they normally do. Uh,
it's been really, really rough and it hasn't been, you know,
you would, you would think, I mean, for everybody, this pandemic has been rough,
but you would think when you go through a crisis that it should be shared,
it should be a shared grief in a shared adversity.
And that's not way it's been, you know, Bernie Sanders treats tweets out,
you know, one of your former opponents, like at least every other day,
tweets out how much some of these billionaires have made during the pandemic.
And, you know,
their net worth is going up and we've got all these people who can't eat.
And that led to your tweet today, which is my favorite.
And we'll probably be going up on a sign in my room when I can get the
calligraphy done about, you know, and I'm not reading the quote right now,
but imagine having the wherewithal to,
you know, solve people's problems and then you don't do it.
I, you know, it's, I can't solve the problems that Jeff Bezos can solve,
but I've been lucky enough I can solve a few people's problems
and you have to do it. I, I love that tweet I've sent it. Uh,
I retweeted it, but a people not on Twitter,
I was sending it out to everybody today. Um, and,
and I think that's where it should be.
We should really be a community, a community of people who are helping others.
Um, but we can't help. We can't count on charity.
That's why to me UBI and things like that,
like we can't depend on charity.
We need systems in place that will help people through this. So.
Well, you know,
one of the reasons why I think that there's something universal about sports and
there's something universal about coaching,
where you form a community with your team, you know,
you're part of a group you're on this together. Uh,
and then you naturally want the same kind of thing for our country when you're
going through a hard time.
It's not like the team's going through a hard time and you just start ignoring
people or singling people out, or just like, pretend some people don't exist.
It's like, okay, who's, uh, who's on the team. Like, you know,
let's come together. Uh,
and here in America we have to all get on the same team. Really.
Like there's just too many problems that are facing folks
for us to just continue all of the, the strange, uh,
strange trend of just everyone blaming the other side for everything,
uh, for turning on each other and singling each other out. Uh, it's,
it's painful for me to stand.
Like it's painful for me to see our country go through this time and
have all these self-inflicted wounds, really. You know, it's like,
like this would be a very rough time, even if we did everything right.
And I would say that for most of us looking at it from the outside,
the NBA was an incredibly high functioning organization and did just about
everything I could do. Right, right. Um, at the bubble.
And then it's in the sharp contrast to most of our other institutions where
everyone's looking around being like, who is supposed to be running the show,
who's supposed to be leading this, uh, the federal government, um,
like has not been leading. Uh, you know, and, and I think you're a coach.
You're like a leader of men. You're a community builder. Uh,
I think it's one of the, why people love sports,
love the NBA is that there's something very human about that. Uh,
and it feels like that's what the country needs right now.
Yeah. To me. And I'm sure to you too,
cause I've heard you speak a lot. Um,
the most frustrating thing is we have the wealth
in this country.
We have the resources to do this and to take care of all of
our people. Now there's countries in the world that are very,
very poor and don't have the wherewithal to take care
of the problems in their country. We have the wealth to do that,
and we just don't have the systems in place and
we don't have the will or to make the sacrifice to
make this a more equal society where everybody can
share in this.
And that's what frustrates me if it was a shared experience and we
just don't have the money to help people. We do,
we have the money to do it.
Well, everyone knows it now, too. Stan, when I was running for president,
people would be like, Oh, like, how do we pay for that? And then we just watch,
uh, our Congress write a $2.2 trillion check mainly to the biggest
companies. And then you're just like, Oh,
we could have done this the whole time.
You know, you can do it. I mean, you can do universal basic income.
You can do Medicare for all or some form of universal
healthcare. You know, whatever's best. I'm not a, I've said to people like, ah,
I'm not, I'm not as smart as you or Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren.
And I haven't gotten as deep into that. Um,
but those possibilities are out there and why we would choose as a wealthy
country to have the levels of poverty.
We have to have the number of people without healthcare and without health
insurance that we have is just mind boggling to me.
And it's a failure in our moral character in our
country. And, and there's no other way to put that. I mean, you just,
you can't sugar coat that you have the resources to take care of these problems.
You refuse to do it. Your moral character is lacking.
I'm not like that's not a partisan thing. That's, that's just the truth.
Yeah. And, uh, it should be a political to stand. It should just be human.
Uh, and, um, unfortunately right now, our politics has become, uh,
inseparable from, uh, from the media narratives, uh,
from frankly the corporate interests,
because so many of our politicians just have very,
very rich corporate interests whispering in their ear all the time. Um,
I'd love to, to change it. I think we have a chance to change it. Uh,
in some measure after Trump is out and Joe and Camila are in,
I believe some very big things will be on the table.
And really then the challenge is going to be,
can we get enough done in let's call it four years, uh,
that people feel like we have genuinely started to come together
and rebuild that trust, not based upon statements,
but upon actually improving people's day-to-day lives and reality like that,
that to me is going to be the challenge over the next number of years,
because if we fail in that, then people's mistrust.
And that, that disintegration of, uh,
the sense of community is just going to accelerate as well.
I feel like we have a window of opportunity here that we have to take full
advantage of. Um, I may play a role in that. Um, but that's,
that's where my head is going now.
As you know, I mean, I think people are realistic.
We're not going to solve all the problems within a,
within a four year term, but I think we can start to solve them.
And I think we can show people in very concrete terms. Like you say,
not in statements, but in things getting done,
we can show people the possibilities of what a better society
could look like for everybody in this country.
And we could set a direction of starting to get there. Um,
that to me is what can happen. And that takes concrete things.
It's not just statements,
but we start to turn around and we get more money in people's
pocket. Um,
heading toward hopefully at least some form of universal,
basic income.
And at least we start working toward getting more people,
health insurance, and you know, all of these problems. Are we going to get,
it turned to 180 degrees in, in four years?
No, that's not realistic, but can you turn it 60 degrees,
70 degrees and give people the feeling we're on the
right track. We can do these things. We have the resources,
we have the leadership, we can do these things.
That's what I'm hoping will happen over the next four years. I'm not,
I'm not expecting Joe Biden, Kamala Harris, people like you.
I hope in the mid administration. That's a great hope for us.
I'm not expecting like, Hey,
they took over January of 21 and it's February now yet. We've got it all.
I got my universal basic income check and we're ready to go.
Yeah. Even if we do everything right, you're right.
That a lot of it's going to be, have we made headway? Have we made progress?
And it's a little bit like if you take over a team,
you're not going to turn around and being like,
we're going to be champions like that. Like, like this year it's like, look,
give me a few years and hopefully we'll have a direction. We'll have a culture.
We'll have a sense of trust, a sense of confidence. Um,
that that's certainly, uh, my vision for the next number of years. Uh, well,
Stan, uh,
such a pleasure with you in a privilege I've been in admire of you and your work
for a long time. Um, you're a force for good, a force for community,
a force for progress in our country.
And I'm looking forward to finding ways that we can work together.
One of my dreams is that, uh, is that universal,
basic income takes root and communities around the country.
And I think that people like you are going to be a big part of it.
I would love to help you in any way. I mean, I think that, you know,
my big, biggest issue has just been justice inequality in every area,
racial justice, G you know, um, women's rights,
uh, you know, LGBTQ rights,
but economic justice is one that just cuts across
all of those and for everybody and makes a true difference in people's
lives. And so if you ever need my help, even in a small way,
I would be,
I would be happy to get on board because I think you've shown us a blueprint.
Now we just have to have the, uh, political will and courage to, uh,
to give it a shot.
Well, thank you, Stan. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.